[Music]
fellas how does it feel to be part of
something so iconic in hollywood like
that of course it's always an honor
to have people remember your work at all
this is my day i'm in the prime of my
youth and i'll only be young once well
it's like a badge of honor
having been a part of stand by me
first come on
for years you know um if people would
ever say hey you were the fact you
didn't stand by me it used to make me
angry like it used to make me like i
can't believe like i'm more than that
[Laughter]
i remember thinking like when are people
gonna stop talking about stand by me all
the time it was a very mature experience
for me to just
resign to the fact that
this movie is not going anywhere
the critically acclaimed coming-of-age
drama also co-starred will wheaton and
the late river phoenix it follows a
group of young friends searching for a
missing dead boy as e.t saw behind the
scenes the actors bonded in real life
while filming in oregon we got along
like like brothers kind of you know
except uh we kind of had our bad moments
too but just like the movie you know and
and it's only natural when you're you
know with uh with these guys for two
three months
do you guys have a favorite scene from
the movie when we do the scene where
we're gonna walk across the swamp you
can see i'm about to laugh
i just couldn't keep it together
just had such a fun time that summer and
that like my face in that shot
it just encapsulizes the whole summer i
literally still have my prosthetic gear
from the film from the actual shoot we
were together i was gonna bring it so
you could have seen the damn here you
have the original wow now i'm really
upset i didn't save anything from stand
by me
well um we got each other buddy we got
each other we're still here i want to
play something for you guys right now
before they play this who do you guys
remember being kind of the troublemaker
of the group i think it was me i thought
it was just crazy but maybe it was you
play this clip for these guys
no he was uh she was crazy he would just
always go oh cool come on you guys got
to let me do this come on come on yeah
we got to do it together this let's go
throw some uh bottle stuff off the
balcony that'd be fun he was natural he
didn't really need any help
we were sitting in a hotel in eugene
oregon there was a pool and we were
always throwing the uh the pool
furniture into the pool
we were all right we're not
nobody children i mean what do you guys
think when you see those baby faces i
think i've never i miss rivers so much
god bless but the sweet guy give me some
skin we'll be friends forever cory we
had a really fun time opening day i got
to see goonies with corey feldman in a
movie theater
but of course since it was jerry's first
movie we had no movie to go see for
jerry you know maybe one day we could
all have a reunion and go see the
kangaroo jack together
you can talk
and i can sing i said a hit pop the
hippie
it's a classic it's a classic
[Music]
you